great don mccarthy beauty and lifestyle
advisor of dawn's corner has some great
products to help us enjoy self-care
awareness month take a look
hi las vegas now take the time this
month to focus on what brings you
happiness and for me that's beauty and
food these are some new beauty launches
and a snack bar you will thank me later
for telling you all about
first up though skin care for men should
not be an afterthought
dionne michaels has created a simple
two-step results driven skin care system
for all men created to tackle their top
skin challenges impacting them from
razor burns to dry beards
at dion michaels when it comes to your
skin their products take you from
ordinary to confident in as little as 14
days with their grooming cream and skin
balm
this product is available for one time
purchase or a monthly subscription which
is 20 off right now for a single
delivery for the month of september
start holiday shopping a little early go
to
dionnemichaels.com to get yours today
that's for you kendall and jc
now if you have bobo fear of breaking
out and not looking good i have the
solution with dermaless oats so sweet
new soothing lightweight moisturizer
formulated with prebiotics and
postbiotics to balance and restore the
skin's microbiome to help with acne its
unique combination of ingredients was
specifically formulated to help calm
restore and feel acne strong skin while
being able to use daily
oats so sweet daily moisturizer is
suitable for any skin type and reduces
redness while hydrating and protecting
the skin
go to dermala.com to find out more
that's d-e-r-m-a-l-a
dot com
next joe's joy of virgin skin as let's
face it unwanted hair is no longer an
issue with the venus pro ipl
joves is a global personal care brand in
the beauty tech space and is the first
of its kind to create innovative hair
removal products while safely treating
the skin making it safe to treat
undesirable hair and more gentle than
laser hair removal it's equipped with a
180 degree rotating head for optimal
precision and comes with a collagen
boosting skin rejuvenation attachment
this at home treatment will give you the
skin of your dreams and having you
feeling baby sauce in no time at all
go to
jobsbeauty.com to learn more about this
must-have
lastly self-care is also about making
sure you are snacking healthy
good to go bars have two grams of sugar
or less and only four to five grams of
net carbs
good to go soft vape bars have a
cake-like texture that you can see below
and the bar can go wherever the day
takes you
the bars are also vegan gluten-free keto
friendly and non-gmo
with almond flour as a base ingredient
their cake-like texture means they won't
melt like other bars either and come in
double chocolate
vanilla almond and chocolate mint
my personal favorite is the vanilla and
truly tastes like a treat go to your
local target or good2gosnax.com
to try some today
so happy self-care awareness month if
you want more information on any of
these products i just featured today
just go to dawnscorner.com
thank you so much don coming up